o psol vai realizar mais um vídeo e hoje
vou ensinar como fazer um avião usando
uma caneta 3d que esteve ontem meirelles
diretória que vocês podem aprender a
fazer na parte final do vídeo
agora estou fazendo um box com uma
caneta que foi enviada pela loja de
herberto se vocês quiserem comprar esta
caneta e filamento vou deixar link na
descrição e esta caneta tem um suporte
que o francês porém canetas inep
aplicará as duas canetas que compra e
não tinham isso então isso é bacana aqui
pronto vocês conseguem ver tudo passo a
passo e vou aproveitar esta parte para
vos agradecer pelo apoio que vocês não
têm dado e graças ao apoio que você não
tem dado no final e nos outros porque
muitas pessoas vão aos outros canais e
comentam e eu responderei aos
comentários de outras pessoas quando
alguém pergunta de onde eu sou é
perguntas sobre mim
muitas pessoas conseguem responder e
responder a itron isso é muito bacana
mesmo e eu queria agradecer é porque não
sou o senhor tem muito tempo essa
organizado mas não tenha tido tempo para
responder comentários e essas coisas é
porque estou pronto e muito tempo na
escola e o tempo que eu tenho o livro e
eu faço vídeos ou seja basicamente não
tenha se muita vida pessoal mas isso
tudo eu fiz durante os últimos tempo
para conseguir realizar um dos meus
sonhos que é ir para a melhor
universidade da animação aqui da
inglaterra e eu consegui
exatamente ao que eu fiquei mesmo por
isso é que o vídeo não tem uma semana e
eu é isso que vim para três
universidades aqui em inglaterra e elas
me chamaram para entrevistas eu fui e
2002 não aceitaram foi a segunda mesmo
por curiosidade também para ver como é
que era a outra mas eu já conhecia
aquela que eu queria ir é e eles
aceitaram logo pelo meu trabalho e não
parece bacana esse que estamos muito
este é nós queremos ver em setembro o
que já dar uma resposta foi mesmo muito
bom finalmente eu moro um tempo para
avaliar o prático yettaw
depois é que dão resposta então eles
deram um blog e nas ruas da cidade
fiquei muito contente achei que com pena
de não ir para alguma tranquilidade
eu fui lá ver pra ver quem sabe a olha
talvez fosse melhor né
aí fui lá e eu falo também super
simpáticos e apenas um sofrido ele numa
e agora sei que muitos de vocês devem
estar confusa mas eu não estava num
sinal agora vai fornecer cidade é isto
num colégio e é que é equivalente à
universidade mas para vocês entenderem é
11 de agosto estudar eu digo nem
retirado porque aqui é a mesma coisa aí
porque não existe colégio em portugal e
no brasil não sei se a uma vez que estou
a fazer um estudo fazer pra mim estou
fazer um curso que é um curso bastante
geral que aborda tudo e com esse curso
conseguir perceber as áreas que eu gosto
mais e quero desenvolver nelas
basicamente eles seriam sempre animação
fizeste curso e percebi que eu não
continuo a gostar mais da animação
destas áreas todas as leis para bonfim é
um estado que a inglaterra é e fui lá e
aqui é mesmo espetacular está em estúdio
trabalhando com diferentes empresas com
animações mesmo muito boas porque pra
mim é um pouco vídeo e não sei o que é
eu não quero fazer esse mundo muito
vídeo porque eu quero também ter tempo
para me desenvolver como pessoa eu não
quero ficar sem fazer o mesmo coisa
quero evoluir e quero melhorar o meu
contínuo com o tempo eu sei que muitas
pessoas deixam universidade chão pela
escola mesmo há opções 12º é sempre
mário que deixam a escola para indicar 8
só que eu quero continuar a desenvolver
um comuns soa como as coisas que eu
consigo fazer por mim o importante não é
as coisas que eu vou adquirindo mas têm
em comum
eu vou evoluindo e isso é difícil de
explicar porque não vou falar
talvez por isso é que sou mais da zona
das artes
vou ficar sonhar mas basicamente é só
pra dizer que estou muito contente mesmo
é isto foi possível graças a vocês
graças a vocês porque este curso e
inglaterra são muito caros mesmo 9 mil
livros só para porã pelo curso mas este
dia mas a comida é fiquei mesmo muito
caro ou seja eu vou gastar meu dinheiro
da internet com o curso
basicamente vocês pagam um curso para
mim mas também pra eu fiz vídeos e muito
tempo e não tinha basicamente de solo no
último ano e tal mas as coisas nós
fazemos coisas que nos sentimos bem e
gostei muito fazer vídeos e não está
também não conseguiria ter estas ideias
e este vídeo é patrocinado pelo dinheiro
mas é bem bacana
temos aqui um patrocínio e estava assim
naquela pode fazer vídeos assim com
patrocínio não porque várias ofertas e
agora uma coisa do youtube ao senado é
tudo bacana não sei que é então de fazer
agora vídeos em patrocinados por que é
bastante bacana e eu vou falar com eles
para fazer um vôo de canetas 3d porque
muitas pessoas não têm
espero que vocês gostem se tiver um bom
feedback e vou falar quando não se quer
fazer igual e de canetas 3d
aí agora até começar as aulas e fazer
bastante vídeos para ter uma reserva
porque quando chegar a hora da
universidade
eu quero me dedicar 100% de freqüência
fizeram um vídeo e 10 para continuar por
um por semana
chegamos ao fim muito muito obrigado por
tudo essas faltas que vocês vão ver aqui
e ter em portugal porque foi o portal
também traz algumas coisas quatro dias a
eles muito obrigado até a próxima terça
ao i